Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The Austrian heir apparent has announced his intention of visiting Sarajevo early next year. Every Serb will take note of this. Serbs, seize everything you can lay hands on. Knives, rifles, bombs, dynamite. Take holy vengeance. Death to the Habsburg dynasty.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。奥地利王储已宣布打算于明年初访问萨拉热窝。每一位塞尔维亚人都将铭记这一点。塞尔维亚人，夺取你们能拿到的一切。刀具、步枪、炸弹、炸药。进行神圣的复仇。哈布斯堡王朝必亡。
Eternal remembrance to the heroes who raised their hands against it. So that was, Dominic, the Serbian emigre newspaper... Svobodan. Svobodan. Svobodan. Which was published in December 1913. And people who've listened to our first episode on the outbreak of the First World War, and we're looking at the build-up to the assassination of Archduke Franz Ferdinand
向那些向它举起反抗之手的英雄们致以永恒的纪念。多米尼克，那是一份塞尔维亚流亡报纸……《自由》（Svobodan）。《自由》。《自由》。它出版于1913年12月。听过我们关于第一次世界大战爆发的第一期节目的听众，以及我们现在正在探讨弗朗茨·斐迪南大公遇刺前的局势，
in Sarajevo by Gavrila Princip, will already have recognized the fact that my mastery of Balkan languages and pronunciation isn't all it can be. But fortunately, master of tongues and Balkan old hand, Dominic Sandbrookok is alongside me. And Dominic, this is an extraordinary story, isn't it? Yeah. So in the first episode, we were looking at the life of Gavrilo Princip. He's grown up a poor peasant. He's moved to Sarajevo. He's very bookish. He's very poor. He's very resentful of Austrian rule. And above all, he wants to see, well, Yugoslavia, a land of the Southern Slavs established in place of Austro-Hungarian rule. And in hope of achieving that, he has gone to Belgrade, the capital of Serbia. So that's where
在萨拉热窝被加夫里洛·普林西普刺杀，应该已经意识到我对巴尔干语言和发音的掌握还远不够好。但幸运的是，语言大师兼巴尔干通多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）就在我身边。多米尼克，这是一个非同寻常的故事，不是吗？是的。所以在第一期节目中，我们探讨了加夫里洛·普林西普的生活。他成长于贫困的农民家庭。他搬到了萨拉热窝。他非常爱读书。他非常贫穷。他对奥地利的统治感到非常愤恨。最重要的是，他希望看到南斯拉夫——一个南斯拉夫人的土地——取代奥匈帝国的统治。为了实现这一目标，他去了塞尔维亚的首都贝尔格莱德。这就是我们
we left the story. And people who listened to that first episode will probably remember that we are actually recording this live in sarajevo aren't we we are we're recording in a wonderful bar called the tesoro on semi multinovia so for anyone who wants to uh who fancies a wonderful bar come and check that out and uh that's why we may get um that kind of background noise the sound of tram so a tram is just going past and dominic we talked in the first episode didn't we that um sarajevo has the first tram system in the austro-hungarian empire very exciting first electric tram yeah so that newspaper that you started with tom it was actually published in chicago so that is a serbian american emigre newspaper so i should have done it in an American accent?
故事中断的地方。听过第一期节目的听众可能还记得，我们实际上是在萨拉热窝现场录制这期节目，对吧？是的，我们是在一家名为“Tesoro”的绝佳酒吧录制的，位于萨拉热窝的Semi-Multinova。所以，如果有人想找一家很棒的酒吧，一定要去看看。这就是为什么我们可能会有那种背景噪音，比如电车的声音——一辆电车刚刚经过。多米尼克，我们在第一期节目中谈到过，萨拉热窝拥有奥匈帝国第一个电车系统，非常令人兴奋，第一辆电动电车。是的，汤姆，你开头提到的那份报纸实际上是在芝加哥出版的，那是一份塞尔维亚裔美国人的流亡报纸。所以我当时应该用美国口音来读吗？
You should have done it in an American accent. Oh, I missed the chance there. You did it in a very aristocratic voice, I thought. Yeah, it's kind of the sound of Serbian liberty. Right, okay, fine. So that actually gives you a sense of the... That's the atmosphere in which Gavrilo Princip is kind of... It's steeped. It's the atmosphere he's hanging around in. We ended last time with him just sort of drifting around these cafes in Belgrade that are full of either people who fought in the Balkan Wars, that have expanded Serbian basically, a young lad in that situation,
你确实应该用美国口音来读。哦，我错过了那个机会。我觉得你读的时候用的是一种非常贵族的腔调。是的，那听起来像是塞尔维亚自由的声音。好吧，没问题。这实际上让你感受到了……这就是加夫里洛·普林西普所沉浸的氛围。这就是他整天混迹的环境。上次我们结束时，他正漫无目的地游荡在贝尔格莱德的咖啡馆里，那里到处都是参加过巴尔干战争的人，那些战争基本上扩张了塞尔维亚。在那种情况下的一个年轻人，
you're intellectual, you're put upon, you want to make a mark. The kind of classic thing you do is basically shoot a member of a royal family, isn't it? That's right. So we looked in the first episode. There've been loads and loads of assassinations of royal figures.
你是知识分子，你受到压迫，你想有所作为。你做的经典之事基本上就是枪杀皇室成员，对吧？没错。所以我们在第一期节目中看了，当时有大量针对皇室人物的暗杀事件。
Yeah. And it's the go-to thing. I mean, it's just what you do. It is. It's fashionable, frankly. There are lots of copycat assassinations of prime ministers of, as you said, kings and queens in the 1890s and 1900s.
是的。这是首选方案。我的意思是，这就是当时人们的做法。确实如此。坦率地说，这很时髦。在19世纪90年代和20世纪初，有很多针对总理、正如你所说的国王和王后的模仿性暗杀。
And as we discussed last time, Princip has this model of this fellow called Bogdan Zerich, who had tried to and failed to shoot the Austrian governor of Bosnia Herzegovina and had then turned the gun on himself and Princip clearly wants to emulate this guy who he thinks is his role model the person that he's thinking about assassinating is actually the new governor of Bosnia who is a guy called General Oskar Potiorek.
正如我们上次讨论的那样，普林西普有一个榜样，就是那个叫波格丹·泽拉伊奇（Bogdan Zerich）的人，他曾试图枪杀奥匈帝国波斯尼亚-黑塞哥维那总督但失败了，随后自尽。普林西普显然想效仿这个他心目中的偶像。他当时想暗杀的人实际上是波斯尼亚的新总督，一个叫奥斯卡·波蒂奥雷克（Oskar Potiorek）将军的人。
And he thinks, obviously, well, I'll succeed where Zerich failed and I'll shoot the governor and that will be a tremendous blow against the Habsburg authority. But then there is this absolutely transformative meeting that by his own account,
他心想，显然，泽拉伊奇失败的地方我会成功，我会枪杀总督，这将是对哈布斯堡权威的沉重打击。但随后发生了那次绝对具有变革意义的会面，据他自己描述，
he has in March 1914. And he's in the coffee house, isn't he, belgrade and who does he meet he meets a guy called nedeljko chabrinovich so he meets his friend as tom so beautifully put it nedeljko chabrinovich that's right and he is from he's from an interesting background his father's coffee merchant in Sarajevo. He conforms, like his friend Gavrilo Princip, to the stereotype. He's a high school dropout. He hasn't found a niche. He's rebelled a little bit against his family.
发生在1914年3月。他当时在贝尔格莱德的咖啡馆里，他遇到了谁呢？他遇到了一个叫内德利科·查布里诺维奇（Nedeljko Chabrinovich）的人。所以他遇到了他的朋友，正如汤姆刚才精彩描述的那样，内德利科·查布里诺维奇。没错，他的背景很有趣，他父亲是萨拉热窝的咖啡商人。他和他的朋友加夫里洛·普林西普一样，符合那种刻板印象。他高中辍学，没找到自己的位置，对家庭有一点叛逆。
And he has become a typesetter for the government printing works in Belgrade. So he has moved from Sarajevo to belgrade as gavrilo did and he is like gavrilo you know he's reading poems he's dreaming about making a name for himself all this kind of stuff now their story that they tell about this meeting in march 1914 goes like this one day chabrinovich got a letter, an anonymous letter, he says, from home, from Sarajevo. And he opened it up, and it just had a newspaper clipping in it. And the newspaper clipping was the announcement that at the end of June that year, 1914, the Austrian heir, Archduke Franz Ferdinand, would be making an official visit to Bosnia
他成了贝尔格莱德政府印刷厂的一名排字工。所以他和加夫里洛一样，从萨拉热窝搬到了贝尔格莱德。他像加夫里洛一样，读着诗，梦想着出人头地，诸如此类。现在，关于1914年3月这次会面，他们讲述的故事是这样的：有一天，查布里诺维奇收到了一封信，他说是一封匿名信，来自家乡萨拉热窝。他打开信，里面只有一张剪报。剪报的内容是宣布那年6月底，即1914年，奥地利王储弗朗茨·斐迪南大公将对波斯尼亚进行正式访问，
in his capacity as the Inspector General of the army to watch some military exercises and to have a tour of Sarajevo. And Shabrinovich tells the story later on at the trial. He says, I took this clipping and I went down to a cafe. Now accounts differ about whether it was the Acorn Garland Cafe or a cafe called the Little Goldfish. anyway one of these cafes they all hang around him gavrilo princip is there and supposedly was there dancing a traditional serbian dance that sounds improbable right when the dance is finished nadeliko comes up to him and says how you doing blah blah look at this look at this newspaper clipping the archduke franz ferdinand is coming to sarajevo now if you believe the more, how shall I put it, the more excitable versions of the story, Gavrilo reads the story,
以陆军总监的身份观看军事演习并巡视萨拉热窝。查布里诺维奇后来在审判中讲述了这个故事。他说：“我拿着剪报去了咖啡馆。”关于那是“橡子花环”咖啡馆还是叫“小金鱼”的咖啡馆，说法不一。总之，在他们混迹的其中一家咖啡馆里，加夫里洛·普林西普也在那里，据说当时正在跳一种传统的塞尔维亚舞蹈，这听起来不太可能，对吧？舞蹈结束后，内德利科走到他身边说：“你好吗，巴拉巴拉，看看这个，看看这个剪报，弗朗茨·斐迪南大公要来萨拉热窝了。”现在，如果你相信这个故事中那些更，我该怎么说呢，更令人兴奋的版本，加夫里洛读了故事，
he says nothing. And then he says to Ciprianovic, meet me here later this evening. So what is amazing is that there is a kind of very heated spy thriller quality to lots of the accounts of what's going on. It's kind of Eric Ambler, isn't it? Very Eric Ambler. But the truth is you don't actually need that kind of sexing up no i mean this really is what's going on exactly it is a kind of murky world of spies and espionage and i suppose the problem with knowing what's going on in espionage stories is that the sources are covered up yeah so that is a problem in working out exactly who is driving this plot, right? And what actually is happening.
他什么也没说。然后他对查布里诺维奇说：“今晚晚些时候在这里见我。”令人惊奇的是，许多关于当时情况的描述都带有一种非常激烈的间谍惊悚片的色彩。这有点像埃里克·安布勒（Eric Ambler）的小说，不是吗？非常埃里克·安布勒。但事实是，你其实并不需要那种添油加醋。不，我的意思是，这确实就是当时发生的事情。这确实是一个充满间谍和情报活动的阴暗世界。我想，了解间谍故事中到底发生了什么的问题在于，消息来源都被掩盖了。是的，所以弄清楚到底是谁在幕后操纵这个阴谋是一个问题，对吧？以及到底发生了什么。
It is because also so many of the accounts of this depend upon what they said at the trial. And actually at the trial, the various conspirators told contradictory stories, stories that often magnified their own role in events, or perhaps sometimes downplayed it as though they were trying to blame somebody else. But also, of course, they may not have known themselves who's operating in the background. So if you want an example
确实如此，因为关于此事的许多描述都依赖于他们在审判中的供词。实际上，在审判中，各共谋者讲述了相互矛盾的故事，这些故事往往夸大了他们在事件中的作用，或者有时又淡化了作用，仿佛他们试图把责任推给别人。但当然，他们自己可能也不知道幕后到底是谁在操纵。所以，如果你想要一个例子，
of the kind of very Gavrilo Princip-centered version of events, there's a brilliant book by Frederick Morton called Thunder at Twilight. And he has this very lush spy through Eric Amblerler passage they finally do meet up in the cafe that evening they go for a walk in the park prince spoke at last softly he asked his friend whether he would help him kill the crown prince of austria silence chabrinovich nodded
关于那种以加夫里洛·普林西普为中心的事件版本，弗雷德里克·莫顿（Frederick Morton）有一本精彩的书叫《黄昏时的雷声》（Thunder at Twilight）。他有那种非常华丽的、埃里克·安布勒式的间谍段落：那天晚上他们终于在咖啡馆见面，他们去公园散步。普林西普终于轻声开口，他问他的朋友是否愿意帮他杀死奥地利王储。沉默。查布里诺维奇点了点头。
silence in prince's blue eyes gleamed the light of a distant lantern i will find the weapons prince said they shook hands all this he can't possibly know this no so people are projecting gleamed the light of a distant lantern. I will find the weapons, Princep said. They shook hands. All this. He can't possibly know this. So people are projecting onto the story elements of spy thrillers that they want to be there. But there are accounts
沉默。普林西普蓝色的眼睛里闪烁着远处灯笼的光芒。“我会找到武器，”普林西普说。他们握了握手。这一切，他不可能知道这些。所以人们是在投射。闪烁着远处灯笼的光芒。“我会找到武器，”普林西普说。他们握了握手。这一切。他不可能知道这些。所以人们是在把他们想要的间谍惊悚片元素投射到故事中。但也有一些描述，
that don't kind of turn into a spy thriller. So Tim Butcher's brilliant book, The Trigger, which we mentioned in the first episode. I mean, he very much advances the case that it is originating with Princep. Yes. So there are a couple of possibilities case that it is originating with Princep. Yes. So there are a couple of possibilities here.
并没有变成间谍惊悚片。比如蒂姆·布彻（Tim Butcher）那本精彩的书《扳机》（The Trigger），我们在第一期节目中提到过。我的意思是，他非常明确地提出了阴谋源于普林西普的观点。是的。所以这里有几种可能性。
Maybe Gavrilo Princep did come up with the idea. Maybe another of his friends did. Or maybe actually they are being manipulated by shadowy forces, Tom, that they don't fully understand. And the only honest answer, actually, historians have put forward rival theories, but the only honest answer is we can never know
也许加夫里洛·普林西普确实想出了这个主意。也许他的另一个朋友想出来的。或者也许他们实际上是被汤姆所说的某种他们并不完全理解的阴暗势力所操纵。而唯一诚实的回答是，实际上历史学家们提出了相互竞争的理论，但唯一诚实的回答是我们永远无法知道，
because there is no paper trail it's quite probable that they didn't know themselves or some of them didn't know themselves actually the person who said the wisest thing about this was uh somebody you were very keen on sir edward gray the british foreign secretary yes great fly fisherman yes he said in the 1920s when people asked him about the origins of the first world war he said probably there is not and there never was any one person who knew all there was to know so and actually i was saying that tom a bosnian military officer walked past us the perfect timing looking at you a little bit suspiciously you're looking at us suspiciously so we're in that world ourselves aren't we are so let's continue with Princip's own account for now as told by Tim Butcher in the trigger he says
因为没有书面记录。很有可能他们自己也不知道，或者他们中的一些人自己也不知道。实际上，关于这一点说得最明智的人是……你非常推崇的一位，英国外交大臣爱德华·格雷爵士（Sir Edward Grey）。是的，伟大的飞蝇钓鱼者。是的，他在20世纪20年代当人们问他关于第一次世界大战的起源时，他说：“可能没有，也从来没有一个人知道所有该知道的事情。”所以，实际上我刚才说的时候，汤姆，一位波斯尼亚军官从我们身边走过，时机太完美了，他有点怀疑地看着你。你正怀疑地看着我们。所以我们自己也身处那个世界，不是吗？是的。那么，让我们继续讲述普林西普自己的描述，正如蒂姆·布彻在《扳机》中所述，他说：
Princip was the driving force behind the plot he gets Trubinovich to help him and another friend of theirs who's Princip's old schoolmate who's also in Belgrade who is a man called Trifko Grabesch and if uh people familiar with the rest of this history want to get a sense of trifco grabesh he looks uncannily like our former producer dom johnson who also looks uncannily like oswald mosley so that might be another way for people to visualize this guy trifco so anyway these three guys, Dom Johnson, Princip, and Srebrenovic, they're meeting up in these cafes, supposedly planning the assassination. And what they do, if you believe this story,
普林西普是阴谋背后的推动力。他让查布里诺维奇帮助他，还有他们的另一个朋友，普林西普的老同学，也住在贝尔格莱德，一个叫特里夫科·格拉贝日（Trifko Grabesch）的人。如果听过《历史的余味》的听众想了解一下特里夫科·格拉贝日，他长得惊人地像我们以前的制片人多姆·约翰逊（Dom Johnson），而多姆·约翰逊又长得惊人地像奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利（Oswald Mosley），所以这可能是人们想象这个叫特里夫科的家伙的另一种方式。总之，这三个人，多姆·约翰逊、普林西普和查布里诺维奇，他们在这些咖啡馆里见面，据说是策划暗杀。如果你相信这个故事，他们所做的就是，
is they get a friend to approach a man called Milan Siganovich. So Milan Siganovich was a war veteran. He had fought in the Balkan Wars. He is a guy who's hanging around that milieu and people know that he has connections to paramilitary groups. So he'd fought against the Bulgarians. He works at the state railways,
他们找了一个朋友去接触一个叫米兰·齐加诺维奇（Milan Siganovich）的人。米兰·齐加诺维奇是一名退伍军人。他参加过巴尔干战争。他是一个混迹于那个圈子的人，人们知道他与准军事组织有联系。所以他曾与保加利亚人作战。他在国家铁路局工作，
but people know him as a man who knows people. He could find you a gun. He'll find you a gun. And after a series of kind of shady cafe meetings, Siganovich says to them, you know, I will find you a gun. I'm really restraining myself from doing a kind of Balkan voice. Good for it, Dominic. That's all the listening with your mastery of Balkan accents.
但人们知道他是一个“门路广”的人。他能帮你找到枪。他会帮你找到枪。在一系列阴暗的咖啡馆会面后，齐加诺维奇对他们说：“你知道，我会帮你们找到枪。”我真的在克制自己不去模仿那种巴尔干口音。多米尼克，加油。这就是你掌握巴尔干口音的全部听力了。
I will find grenades. Right. So he finds them the gun. He finds them the grenades. And then he leads them out of Belgrade, doesn't he? Up to a park. Yes. Which I read had the brilliant name Belgrade, doesn't he? Yeah. Up to a park. Yes. Which I read had the brilliant name of Top Cider.
“我会找到手榴弹。”好吧。所以他帮他们找到了枪。他帮他们找到了手榴弹。然后他把他们带出了贝尔格莱德，不是吗？带到了一个公园。是的，我读到过那个公园有一个绝妙的名字，贝尔格莱德，不是吗？是的。带到了一个公园。是的，我读到过那个公园有一个绝妙的名字，叫托普奇德尔（Top Cider）。
Top Cider. So kind of like a strong bow or something. Right. He takes them to Top Cider Park, which is just outside Belgrade. It's half sort of park, half forest. And he says, right, I'm going to train you now on how to use the grenades and how to use the pistols. Now, let's stop the narrative right there. In one of those films where the guy says,
托普奇德尔。听起来有点像苹果酒（Strongbow）之类的。没错。他把他们带到了贝尔格莱德郊外的托普奇德尔公园。那地方一半是公园，一半是森林。他说：“好了，我现在要训练你们如何使用手榴弹和手枪。”现在，让我们就在这里停下叙述。在那些电影里，主角会说：
how did I get here? Let's stop right there. Where has Milan Siganovich got these weapons from? Well, I know. You know this? I do know the answer to this. Oh, great. So I was reading this in Christopher Clarke's The Sleepwalkers. Yeah.
“我怎么会到这里来的？”让我们就在这里停下。米兰·齐加诺维奇是从哪里弄到这些武器的？嗯，我知道。你知道这个？我确实知道答案。哦，太好了。我是在克里斯托弗·克拉克（Christopher Clarke）的《梦游者》（The Sleepwalkers）里读到的。是的。
That previously, the Serbs had got their armaments from a French company. And this was an arrangement that had begun in 1906. And previously, they had got it from the Austro-Hungarian Empire based in Prague, a company called Skoda. And my eyes lit up because we have just bought a Skoda Yeti, which is very popular for people who live on Scottish estates. They all have them. Theo, their producer, is absolutely appalled by this revelation.
在此之前，塞尔维亚人是从一家法国公司获得军火的。这是一个始于1906年的安排。而在此之前，他们是从位于布拉格的奥匈帝国公司，一家叫斯柯达（Skoda）的公司获得的。我的眼睛亮了起来，因为我们刚买了一辆斯柯达Yeti，这在住在苏格兰庄园的人中非常受欢迎。他们都有这种车。他们的制片人西奥（Theo）对这个发现感到非常震惊。
Shaking his head very sadly. It's self-indulgence, isn't it, Theo? So listen, you're right. The Serbs, as part of their geopolitical rebalancing, their reorienting, had reoriented towards France and Russia, away from Austria-Hungary. But we don't need to get too deep into that now. Siganovich gets these weapons from another man
他非常悲伤地摇着头。这是一种自我放纵，不是吗，西奥？所以听着，你是对的。塞尔维亚人作为其地缘政治再平衡、重新定位的一部分，已经从奥匈帝国转向了法国和俄罗斯。但我们现在不需要深入探讨那个问题。齐加诺维奇从另一个人那里得到了这些武器，
called Major Vojislav Tankusic. So Tankusic, who is in the Serbian army, has got them six bombs and four revolvers. We know that he obtained them from a Belgrade arms dealer in December 1913. So Tankosic is affiliated with a nationalist group called Narodna Odbrana, National Defense. This had been set up in Serbia after the Austrians had annexed Bosnia-Herzegovina. So people were obviously very cross about that. And they had said, let's form an organization that will fight for Bosnia to become Yugoslav, to become part of a greater Serbia. And they had lots of sort of supporters in towns and
叫沃伊斯拉夫·坦科西奇（Vojislav Tankusic）少校。所以坦科西奇，他在塞尔维亚军队中，给了他们六枚炸弹和四把左轮手枪。我们知道他是1913年12月从贝尔格莱德的一名军火商那里获得的。所以坦科西奇隶属于一个叫“民族防卫”（Narodna Odbrana）的民族主义组织。这是在奥地利吞并波斯尼亚-黑塞哥维那之后在塞尔维亚成立的。所以人们显然对此非常愤怒。他们说：“让我们成立一个组织，为波斯尼亚成为南斯拉夫的一部分、成为大塞尔维亚的一部分而战。”他们在塞尔维亚各地的城镇和
villages across Serbia. They had supporters in Bosnia. They trained people. They would say, we would train volunteers to be guerrillas, to be paramilitaries. But actually, Narodna Odbrana doesn't really, it's a bit of a talking shop.
村庄里有很多支持者。他们在波斯尼亚也有支持者。他们训练人们。他们会说，我们训练志愿者成为游击队员，成为准军事人员。但实际上，“民族防卫”并没有真正……它有点像是一个清谈馆。
It's kind of well-known, it's public, but they don't carry out any... Is it actually a front for a much more shadowy organization? It is. We love a shadowy organization. Would this organization in serbian
它有点出名，是公开的，但他们并没有执行任何……它实际上是一个更阴暗组织的幌子吗？是的。我们喜欢阴暗组织。这个组织在塞尔维亚语里
yeah be called the ujet in genji illy schmert with an exclamation mark and uh so that's some union or death do you want me to tell you how to pronounce it yeah go on because you've got to raise your voice at the end of that because there is an exclamation mark and again it i like it because it reminds me uh eliza my younger daughter when she wrote her name would always put an exclamation mark really after her name frankie you're you're in very um self-referential form in today's episode tom this is the way i'm approaching it i have to say i'm not familiar with this story at all so this organization union or death or unification or death is better known by its extraordinary nickname the black hand
是的，会被称为“Ujedinjenje ili Smrt”，后面带一个感叹号。所以那是“联合或死亡”。你想让我告诉你怎么发音吗？是的，说吧，因为你最后得提高嗓门，因为有一个感叹号。而且我喜欢它，因为它让我想起我的小女儿伊丽莎（Eliza），她写名字时总会加一个感叹号。弗兰基，你今天真是太……自我指涉了，汤姆。这就是我处理它的方式。我必须说，我对这个故事一点也不熟悉。所以这个组织“联合或死亡”或“统一或死亡”，更广为人知的名字是它非同寻常的绰号——“黑手”（The Black Hand）。
the black hand yeah the black hand is very tinted isn't it or very I mean everything about this is tinted now I would say the vast majority of historians who've written about this believe that actually it is the black hand that came up with the plot why is it called the black hand it's just a great name and as you will see they just made it up though I mean because I thought it was called union or death it is called union death but it becomes known as the black hand and as we will see but why does it become known as the black hand because it's a good name right okay but as we will see tom having a name like the black hand and having that kind of reputation is really important to this organization for political purposes it's kind of like sectarian
“黑手”，是的，“黑手”听起来很有丁丁历险记的感觉，不是吗？或者非常……我的意思是，关于这一切的一切现在都带上了那种色彩。我想说，绝大多数写过这件事的历史学家都认为，实际上是“黑手”策划了这个阴谋。为什么叫“黑手”？这只是一个很棒的名字。正如你将看到的，他们只是编造出来的。因为我以为它叫“联合或死亡”。它确实叫“联合或死亡”，但它后来被称为“黑手”。正如我们将会看到的，但为什么它被称为“黑手”？因为这是一个好名字，对吧？好吧，但正如我们将会看到的，汤姆，拥有像“黑手”这样的名字并拥有那种名声，对于这个组织来说，出于政治目的是非常重要的。它有点像宗派主义的
masons basically it is we'll get on onto that so most historians have written about this believe that the black hand are directing the whole thing and that princip and his friends are actually useful idiots as thomas otty says in his book july crisis they're useful idiots zealous but ignorant and so deniable so union or death the black hand was founded in 1911 so it's founded in between the bosnian annexation crisis and the first balkan war it has seven original founding members most of them are people who had taken part in the conspiracy we talked about last time to murder the king and queen of serbia so the regicides so these guys have done this hideous murder and are still hanging around kind of nationalist paramilitary politics one of them's got a breast in his briefcase, right? Exactly. Breast of the murdered queen.
共济会，基本上就是这样。我们稍后会谈到。所以大多数写过这件事的历史学家都认为，“黑手”在指挥整个事情，而普林西普和他的朋友们实际上是“有用的白痴”，正如托马斯·奥特（Thomas Otte）在他的书《七月危机》（July Crisis）中所说的那样。他们是“有用的白痴”，狂热但无知，而且是可以被否认的。所以“联合或死亡”、“黑手”成立于1911年，也就是在波斯尼亚吞并危机和第一次巴尔干战争之间。它有七名最初的创始成员，他们中的大多数人都是我们上次谈到的谋杀塞尔维亚国王和王后的阴谋的参与者。也就是弑君者。所以这些家伙犯下了这种可怕的谋杀案，现在仍然在搞那种民族主义准军事政治。其中一个人公文包里还有一块乳房，对吧？没错。被谋杀王后的乳房。
Major Tankasic is one of them. But the most famous one, the guiding light of the organization is a man we talked about last time, Dragutin Dimitrievic, the head who is now the head of Serbian military intelligence. And he is the guy who has the nickname Apis after the Egyptian bull god. So the Black Hand is a very aggressive Serbian nationalist group. Its goal, its explicit goal in its constitution is the unification of Serbdom. And they go all in on their newspaper. The Black Hand publishes a newspaper which is called Piedmont, as in Piedmont in Italy.
坦科西奇少校就是其中之一。但最著名的一个，该组织的指路明灯，是我们上次谈到的一个人，德拉古廷·迪米特里耶维奇（Dragutin Dimitrievic），他现在是塞尔维亚军事情报局的局长。他就是那个绰号叫“阿皮斯”（Apis）的人，取自埃及公牛神的名字。所以“黑手”是一个非常有侵略性的塞尔维亚民族主义组织。它的目标，其章程中明确的目标是“塞尔维亚人的统一”。他们全力以赴地利用他们的报纸。“黑手”出版了一份报纸，叫《皮埃蒙特》（Piedmont），就像意大利的皮埃蒙特一样。
The idea is that South Slavs should be united in a greater Serbian kingdom. They are much more Serbian nationalists, actually, than Gavrili Principists. So they say, Croats don't exist. They're really Serbs. Bosnian Muslims should give up Islam. They are Serbs, too. And you asked about the name. The reason they have a kind of nickname like that the
其理念是南斯拉夫人应该在一个大塞尔维亚王国中统一起来。实际上，他们比加夫里洛·普林西普主义者更倾向于塞尔维亚民族主义。所以他们说：“克罗地亚人不存在。他们实际上是塞尔维亚人。波斯尼亚穆斯林应该放弃伊斯兰教。他们也是塞尔维亚人。”你问到了名字。他们之所以有像“黑手”这样的绰号，是因为
black hand is because apis loves nicknames and he believes you know you said it was freemason style he believes that they should have a reputation as shadowy secretive lots of rituals lots of symbols so they make up a ceremony where you will go into a darkened room. There will be a bloke in a hood and he will force you to swear obedience to the organization by the blood of my ancestors on my honor and on my life. I will until death be faithful to the organization. I'll make any sacrifice for it. And there's a kind of altar and there's all this stuff. And this is all kind of it's window dressing it's fun it's sexy it's glamorous and if you are a gavrilo princip type you love all this
阿皮斯喜欢绰号，他相信……你说过这是共济会风格……他相信他们应该拥有阴暗、神秘、充满仪式和符号的名声。所以他们编造了一个仪式：你走进一个黑暗的房间。会有一个戴兜帽的人，他会强迫你以祖先的鲜血、以我的荣誉和我的生命起誓，服从该组织。“我将至死忠于该组织。我将为此做出任何牺牲。”那里有一个祭坛，还有所有这些东西。这都是一种装饰，很有趣，很性感，很迷人。如果你是加夫里洛·普林西普那种类型的人，你会喜欢这一切。
so can i ask we heard in the previous episode that these guys are all busy reading sherlock holmes and other kind of spy detective kind of stories. Are these influencing this? Absolutely. So is it the interface between fictional spies and real life spies is becoming blurred? Totally they are, Tom. Thomas Otte says in his book, it's like something from the Scarlet Pimpernel. It is exactly like something from the Scarlet Pimpernel.
我可以问一下吗？我们在上一集听说这些家伙都在忙着读夏洛克·福尔摩斯和其他那种间谍侦探故事。这些有影响吗？绝对有。所以虚构间谍和现实间谍之间的界面正在变得模糊？完全是这样，汤姆。托马斯·奥特在他的书中说，这就像《红花侠》（The Scarlet Pimpernel）里的情节。这确实就像《红花侠》里的情节。
Not coincidentally. Which had been published a few years earlier. So in the 1900s, there are across Europe, lots of stories of secret societies of spies detectives of course all of these things being published and apis and his colleagues design the organization specifically to appeal to people who've read these stories hence the name are you going to join union or death if you're 16. Are you going to join the Union of Death if you're 16? Maybe. Are you going to join the Black Hand?
并非巧合。它是在几年前出版的。所以在20世纪初，欧洲各地出版了许多关于间谍、侦探秘密社团的故事，所有这些东西都在出版。阿皮斯和他的同事们专门设计了这个组织，以吸引那些读过这些故事的人，这就是名字的由来。如果你16岁，你会加入“联合或死亡”吗？如果你16岁，你会加入“联合或死亡”吗？也许吧。你会加入“黑手”吗？
Of course you are. Very exciting, very glamorous. So it spreads very quickly. It had 2,500 members or so by 1911, but during the Balkan Wars, gets thousands and thousands more.
当然会。非常令人兴奋，非常迷人。所以它传播得非常快。到1911年，它大约有2500名成员，但在巴尔干战争期间，又增加了成千上万名。
So the other thing, the other obvious question is, a shadowy organization called the Black Hand. Yeah. I mean, it couldn't be more obvious, could it? Yeah yeah but the obviousness is the point it's in plain sight so he wants to seem menacing they want to be menacing they would they would meet in cafes and apis would be there he would be presiding at the table and other people looking in basically with their noses
所以另一件事，另一个显而易见的问题是，一个叫“黑手”的阴暗组织。是的。我的意思是，这再明显不过了，不是吗？是的，是的，但这种显而易见正是重点所在。它就在众目睽睽之下。所以他想显得具有威胁性，他们想显得具有威胁性。他们会在咖啡馆里见面，阿皮斯会坐在那里，他会主持会议，其他人会看着，基本上是把鼻子
pressed the window like oh my god the black hand i would love to be at the table i would love to know what they are what they are talking about and of course learning their secrets learning their secrets the rituals obviously people find fascinating but also the point about the black hand of course is that it claims to represent the mass of the serbian nation so in other words a degree of being public facing is very important to it now there is a dark obviously i'd say there is a dark side to the black hand of course there's a dark no they have i mean christopher clark uses the expression a terrorist training camp he's not wrong they do run terrorist training camps and they show you
贴在窗户上，就像“天哪，黑手，我真想坐在那张桌子旁，我真想知道他们在谈论什么。”当然，学习他们的秘密，学习他们的秘密。仪式显然人们觉得很迷人，但“黑手”的重点当然是它声称代表了塞尔维亚民族的大多数。换句话说，一定程度的公开面对公众对它来说非常重要。现在，显然有一个黑暗面，我会说“黑手”有一个黑暗面，当然有一个黑暗面。不，他们……我的意思是，克里斯托弗·克拉克用了“恐怖分子训练营”这个词，他没说错。他们确实经营着恐怖分子训练营，他们向你展示
literally how to be a terrorist how to assassinate somebody how to throw a bomb how to blow up a bridge all of those things i mean it's a bit like um al-qaeda would which somebody how to throw a bomb how to blow up a bridge all of those things i mean it's a bit like um al-qaeda would which was supposed to be a kind of shadowy underground organization would nevertheless release videos showing their recruits kind of crawling under barbed wire and of course they did things like that i mean basically it's the same i mean you can see the line of descent there it's exactly the same same. I mean, it's on the IRA funerals. Yeah. People would publicly turn up in balaclavas shooting guns over the grave.
字面上如何成为一名恐怖分子，如何暗杀某人，如何投掷炸弹，如何炸毁桥梁，所有这些事情。我的意思是，这有点像……基地组织，它本应是一个某种阴暗的地下组织，但仍然会发布视频，展示他们的招募人员在铁丝网下爬行，当然他们确实做过这样的事情。我的意思是，基本上是一样的。我的意思是，你可以看到那种传承，完全一样。我的意思是，这就像爱尔兰共和军的葬礼。是的。人们会公开戴着巴拉克拉瓦头套出现在葬礼上，在坟墓上开枪。
So a lot of terrorist groups, nationalist terrorist groups or ideological terrorist groups have a kind of public face and the black hand is one of them. So I guess the next question is, okay, so the black hand, if they are behind it,
所以很多恐怖组织，民族主义恐怖组织或意识形态恐怖组织都有某种公众形象，“黑手”就是其中之一。所以我猜下一个问题是，好吧，那么“黑手”，如果他们是幕后黑手，
why would they want to do such a spectacular and dangerous operation? Why would they want to kill Franz Ferdinand? Now, one thing to say right away is, of course, there's no paper trail. Apis used to burn his papers regularly, of course, because he's the head of Serbian intelligence,
他们为什么要进行这样一场引人注目且危险的行动？他们为什么要杀死弗朗茨·斐迪南？现在，首先要说的一点是，当然，没有书面记录。阿皮斯经常烧毁他的文件，当然，因为他是塞尔维亚情报局的局长，
so he's bound to do that. We have a pretty good idea that much as the kind of Gavrilo Princip centric version holds the original plan was probably to kill the governor of Bosnia General Potiorek you know that would make sense it doesn't necessarily need to be traced back to Belgrade it could have just been local people who did it so it's deniable right but it seems that in the spring of 1914, they changed their focus to the Archduke. Christopher Clarke in his book, The Sleepwalkers,
所以他肯定会那样做。我们有相当好的把握认为，尽管那种以加夫里洛·普林西普为中心的版本认为最初的计划可能是杀死波斯尼亚总督波蒂奥雷克将军，你知道，这说得通，它不一定需要追溯到贝尔格莱德，可能只是当地人做的，所以它是可以被否认的，对吧？但似乎在1914年春天，他们把重点转向了大公。克里斯托弗·克拉克在他的书《梦游者》中，
says he thinks he knows, he's basically drawing on other authors, but he says, we think we know who the person is who first suggested it, a guy called Rade Malobabic. Now he worked, he kind of used to cross the border between Bosnia and Serbia.
说他认为他知道，他基本上是在借鉴其他作者的观点，但他说是的，我们认为我们知道第一个提出这个建议的人是谁，一个叫拉德·马洛巴比奇（Rade Malobabic）的家伙。现在他工作……他经常往返于波斯尼亚和塞尔维亚边境。
Is this the guy who would swim yes freezing rivers and when he came up his mustache would have icicles hanging from it that guy it's exactly that guy tom again very tintin so i mean christopher clark describes him as a super agent a man of extraordinary dedication and cunning who knew the borderlands well i mean the thing that strikes me having done the jfk yeah story where we ended up very decisively coming down on the argument that lee harvey oswald was a lone assassin and that there wasn't a massive conspiracy behind it yeah i mean all this seems in a way a much more implausible conspiracy than some of the conspiracies that are told about the jfk. Except that we know that these...
这就是那个会游泳的家伙吗？是的，在冰冷的河流中，当他上来时，他的胡子上会有冰柱挂着，就是那个家伙。汤姆，又是非常丁丁历险记的感觉。所以，我的意思是，克里斯托弗·克拉克形容他是一名超级特工，一个具有非凡奉献精神和狡猾的人，非常了解边境地区。我的意思是，在做了肯尼迪（JFK）的故事后，我们最终非常果断地得出了李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德（Lee Harvey Oswald）是单独刺客，背后没有大规模阴谋的结论，这让我感到震惊。是的，我的意思是，所有这一切在某种程度上似乎是一个比关于肯尼迪的那些阴谋更不可信的阴谋。除了我们知道这些……
The black hand, people with icicles from their moustaches. I mean, it's all... Yeah, it's the Balkans, Tom. They do think differently there. Well, you are the Balkan hand. I think we can be pretty sure, the vast majority of historians believe the black hand is an organization set up for precisely this purpose.
“黑手”，胡子上挂着冰柱的人。我的意思是，这一切……是的，这是巴尔干半岛，汤姆。他们在那里的思维方式确实不同。好吧，你是巴尔干通。我想我们可以相当确定，绝大多数历史学家认为“黑手”是一个正是为了这个目的而成立的组织。
We can trace connections between some of these people. We know that they talk to each other. We know certainly that the weapons came from them. Okay. Okay. Well, that is clinching. Yeah. And I suppose also the whole thing about Princip is that he's not a lone agent. No, he's not a lone gunman. So that makes him different from Lihard V. Oswald and so many more recent assassins. He genuinely is part of a conspiracy. I mean, on the day, there were six people there with grenades and revolvers. So the question is, why would they go for such a potentially dangerous operation? Now, the first reason is Franz Josef, the emperor of Austria-Hungary, is very old. He's about 140. He has been emperor since 1848. He is ill in the spring of 1914. He's got pneumonia.
我们可以追踪这些人之间的一些联系。我们知道他们互相交谈。我们当然知道武器确实来自他们。好吧。好吧。嗯，那确实是决定性的。是的，而且我想关于普林西普的整件事是，他不是一个单独的特工。不，他不是一个单独的枪手。所以这使他与李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德以及许多更近期的刺客不同。他确实是阴谋的一部分。我的意思是，在那一天，有六个人带着手榴弹和左轮手枪在那里。所以问题是，他们为什么要进行这样一场潜在的危险行动？现在，第一个原因是，奥匈帝国皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫（Franz Josef）非常老了。他大约140岁了。他自1848年以来一直担任皇帝。他在1914年春天病得很重。他得了肺炎。
So it looks as though he's going to die. His heir will succeed. So assassinating the heir that spring, that summer, would be a massive blow against the Habsburg monarchy and Habsburg authority. But I think there are two other political considerations. First of all, Apis and other people in kind of the Serbian paramilitary milieu believe that Franz Ferdinand, the Archduke, is the leader of a war party in Austria-Hungary that is itching to strike at Serbia. Which he is not, is he? It's actually the opposite. Totally the opposite. On this, they are totally and utterly wrong, as we will see next time. Franz Ferdinand, the last thing he wants. he is the single biggest obstacle to a war with Serbia
所以看起来他快要死了。他的继承人将继位。因此，在那个春天、那个夏天暗杀继承人，将是对哈布斯堡王朝和哈布斯堡权威的沉重打击。但我认为还有两个政治考量。首先，阿皮斯和塞尔维亚准军事圈子里的其他人认为，弗朗茨·斐迪南大公是奥匈帝国主战派的领袖，渴望打击塞尔维亚。但他并不是，对吧？实际上恰恰相反。完全相反。在这一点上，他们完全彻底地错了，正如我们下次将看到的。弗朗茨·斐迪南，他最不想要的就是战争。他是反对与塞尔维亚开战的最大障碍。
the second thing is they know and on this they are quite right that Franz Ferdinand has extensive plans for when he becomes emperor that will involve reforming the empire and possibly setting up a south slav kingdom within the Austro-Hungarian Empire, or even moving towards a United States of Greater Austria that will give the Slav subjects much more autonomy. If you're a Serbian ultra-nationalist, that is a chilling prospect because that will destroy your dreams of a Greater Serbia because all of these Slavs within the Austro-Hungarian Empire, why would they want to ally with you, this kingdom of two million people, very poor, when they can actually have much more
第二件事是，他们知道，而且在这一点上他们是对的，弗朗茨·斐迪南有广泛的计划，在他成为皇帝后，将涉及改革帝国，并可能在奥匈帝国境内建立一个南斯拉夫王国，甚至走向一个“大奥地利合众国”，这将给予斯拉夫臣民更多的自治权。如果你是一个塞尔维亚极端民族主义者，那是一个令人不寒而栗的前景，因为那将摧毁你建立“大塞尔维亚”的梦想，因为所有这些奥匈帝国境内的斯拉夫人，当他们实际上可以在一个更发达、更富裕的奥匈帝国大共同市场内拥有更多自治权时，为什么还要与你们这个只有两百万人口、非常贫穷的王国结盟呢？
autonomy within a big common market of Austria-Hungary that is far more developed, richer, and so on and so forth. Princip at the trial said, as a future ruler, Franz Ferdinand would have prevented our union by realizing certain reforms that would have been against our interests and i think that is absolutely crucial and why the black hand decided to go for this and so they're plotting against him not just because he is a symbol of the hautsberg monarchy but for specific policy reasons exactly embodied they think in what his plans will be and remember he becomes emperor if the emperor is ill there is a possibility Franz Ferdinand could be emperor within weeks, within months.
普林西普在审判中说：“作为未来的统治者，弗朗茨·斐迪南会通过实现某些违背我们利益的改革来阻止我们的统一。”我认为这绝对是至关重要的，也是“黑手”决定采取行动的原因。所以他们密谋反对他，不仅因为他是哈布斯堡王朝的象征，而且出于具体的政策原因，他们认为这些原因具体体现在他的计划中。记住，如果皇帝病重，他就会成为皇帝，弗朗茨·斐迪南有可能在几周、几个月内成为皇帝。
So they want to get rid of him before that happens. So once they've approved the plan, both Thomas Otte and Christopher Clarke think that at that point, maybe March 1914, that it's probably them who recruit
所以他们想在他发生这种情况之前除掉他。所以一旦他们批准了计划，托马斯·奥特和克里斯托弗·克拉克都认为，在那一刻，即1914年3月，可能就是他们招募了
Princip, Czerbrinovich and Grabesch, even if they don't really know they're being recruited. They're groomers. This is what Christopher Clarke says. He uses the word grooming. And he says, these are young men, very young men, teenagers, some of them, who are unhappy, lonely, no friends, no girlfriend, no money.
普林西普、查布里诺维奇和格拉贝日，即使他们并不真正知道自己被招募了。他们是“诱导者”。这就是克里斯托弗·克拉克所说的。他用了“诱导”（grooming）这个词。他说，这些是年轻人，非常年轻的人，有些还是青少年，他们不快乐、孤独、没有朋友、没有女朋友、没有钱。
And they are approached by older men who they look up to, war veterans who approach them in these cafes and say oh you're a great man i have an important mission for you and all of this yeah you can absolutely see why they would you know be seduced by this major tankers which clearly decides he's going to be the person who handles the operation but he hides behind a go-between which is this guy tsiganovich so he's the guy who gives them the weapons and takes them to the park and now we get back tom to that point in the narrative yeah where they're in the park and just to a reminder that um the aims of the black hand which are very serbian and those of princip who's very
他们被他们仰慕的年长者接近，那些在咖啡馆里接近他们的退伍军人说：“哦，你是个伟大的人，我有一个重要的任务交给你。”所有这些……是的，你绝对可以看出为什么他们会被这种诱惑。坦科西奇少校显然决定他要成为处理这次行动的人，但他躲在一个中间人后面，也就是这个叫齐加诺维奇的家伙。所以他就是那个给他们武器并带他们去公园的人。现在我们回到汤姆叙述中的那一点，
pan-slav are actually Yeah, it's a difference of nuance, but it is a genuine difference. Princip, he doesn't really dream of a greater kingdom of Serbia. He thinks of Serbia as the Prussia in a kind of Germany. Whereas Apis and Co, I think when they talk about a South Slav union, they mean you either will call yourself Serbs or you'll be second class citizens under the serbs yeah anyway they're in the park top cheetah park so you kind of it shows them the bombs and the pistols so the bombs first of all i mean they're terrifying reading about how you you set off a bomb i absolutely would not have wanted to do it we would call them grenades
他们在公园里。只是提醒一下，“黑手”的目标是非常塞尔维亚的，而普林西普的目标是非常泛斯拉夫的，实际上……是的，这是一种细微差别的差异，但这是一个真正的差异。普林西普，他并不真正梦想一个大塞尔维亚王国。他认为塞尔维亚是某种德国中的普鲁士。而阿皮斯等人，我认为当他们谈论南斯拉夫联盟时，他们的意思是，你要么称自己为塞尔维亚人，要么你就是塞尔维亚人统治下的二等公民。是的，总之他们在公园里，托普奇德尔公园。所以他向他们展示了炸弹和手枪。所以首先是炸弹，我的意思是，读到你如何引爆炸弹真是太可怕了，我绝对不想那样做。我们会称它们为手榴弹，
but they don't look like grenades they're kind of like um like the kind of ice packs that you put in your freezer yeah so they're rectangular and they have a kind of cap on them so you can put them they're small enough to put inside your jacket pockets they've got a cap on them to activate the bomb you basically have to knock the cap off to get it off you basically knock the bomb against a lamppost or something so the cap falls falls off. Then you have 12 seconds. And Suganovich says, count to 10. I mean, who would do this? Count to 10 and then throw.
但它们看起来不像手榴弹。它们有点像……你放在冰箱里的那种冰袋。是的，所以它们是长方形的，上面有一个盖子。所以你可以把它们……它们足够小，可以放进你的夹克口袋里。它们上面有一个盖子。要激活炸弹，你基本上必须把盖子敲掉。要把它弄下来，你基本上要把炸弹对着灯柱之类的东西敲一下，这样盖子就会掉下来。然后你有12秒的时间。齐加诺维奇说：“数到10。”我的意思是，谁会这样做？数到10然后扔。
So you throw with only two seconds to go. And, you know, as historians say, these are very unreliable. So it's about 12 seconds. Yes. So you don't want to miscalculate. And sometimes they don't explode. Or sometimes they just go off in your faceate and sometimes they don't explode or sometimes
所以你只剩两秒钟的时候扔。而且，正如历史学家所说，这些非常不可靠。所以大约是12秒。是的。所以你不想算错。有时它们不会爆炸。或者有时它们只是在你的脸上爆炸……有时它们不会爆炸，或者有时
they just go off in your face or sometimes they might explode earlier yeah they're meant to so they've got those lots of jeopardy and then they have uh nine millimeter browning semi-automatic pistols so these have been used a lot by serbian paramilitaries in the balkan wars and they practice their marksmanship in this park and And Princip, by all accounts, is the best marksman. So they practice the shooting, all good. They do two weeks of practice. Saganowicz says, brilliant, now you know everything. They go back to the Goldfish Cafe to have a celebration.
它们只是在你的脸上爆炸，或者有时它们可能会提前爆炸。是的，它们本意是……所以它们有很多风险。然后他们有9毫米勃朗宁半自动手枪。这些手枪在巴尔干战争中被塞尔维亚准军事人员大量使用。他们在公园里练习射击。普林西普据说是最好的射手。所以他们练习射击，一切都好。他们进行了两周的练习。齐加诺维奇说：“太棒了，现在你们什么都知道了。”他们回到“金鱼”咖啡馆庆祝。
Princip rather miserably drinks mineral water because, of course, he doesn't drink. Oh, and there's one more thing, Tom. They are given cyanide as well. Of course. So that after they've committed the assassination, they can bite on it and die. And I suppose, from the point of view
普林西普喝着矿泉水，样子相当痛苦，因为他当然是不喝酒的。哦，还有一件事，汤姆。他们还被发了氰化物。当然是为了让他们在行刺成功后，可以咬破它自尽。我想，从那些幕后策划者的角度来看——如果他们真的存在的话——这才是关键。因为你得让他们消失。所以氰化物对所有人都有用。正如你所说，如果他们真的在操控这一切，这对“黑手党”也有利，因为他们杀掉了自己的特工，这样特工就无法指认他们了；而对于普林西普和他的同伙来说，这意味着他们
of the shadowy organizers, if they exist, that's the key. Because you want them out of the way. So it works for everybody there, the cyanide. It works, as you said, if they genuinely are controlling this, it works for the Black Hand, because they kill their operatives who can't then identify them for princip and co it means they
实现了他们梦寐以求的命运，就像科索沃的那个人，或者1910年的刺客一样，他们为了一个对他们来说非常重要的崇高理想而牺牲了自己的生命。我能问一下吗？你可能不知道答案，但我知道你对军火很感兴趣。是的。把自己伪装成自杀式炸弹袭击者，在身上缠满炸药，然后把自己和汽车里的某位大公一起炸飞，这难道不可行吗？
fulfill the destiny that they have dreamed of which is like the guy at kosovo or like the guy in 1910 assassins who had then died and sacrificed their lives for a greater ideal that is really important to them can i just ask and you may not know the answer to this, but I know you're interested in munitions. Yeah. It wasn't possible to set yourself up as a suicide bomber, to wrap yourself so tightly with explosives that you could blow yourself and, say, an archduke in a car.
嗯，我是说，关于拔掉引信盖子的事，汤姆，那会……首先，你看起来会像米其林轮胎人一样，浑身都是……我知道，但我只是在想，也许你可以点燃导火索之类的。不，不，我不认为这行得通。这些手榴弹不行，你会摇摇晃晃地走在街上，所有这些手榴弹都会撞到灯柱之类的东西。那会是一个非常混乱的场面，因为一旦你拔掉了一个，你就得把剩下的也都拔掉。
Well, I mean, this thing about knocking the cap off, Tom, that would be... You'd look like the Michelin man first of all with all this i know but i just wonder i mean you maybe you light a fuse or something no no i don't think that could be done so not with these grenades you'd be lurching across the street all these grenades like banging into lampposts and stuff. It would just be a shambolic figure because once you'd knocked one off, you then have to knock all the other ones off.
12秒内拔掉所有剩下的。是的。是的，抱歉。这太荒谬了。深入研究军火很有意思。确实如此。自杀式炸弹袭击。他还给了他们一个信封。
12 seconds to knock all the others off. Yeah. Yeah, sorry. This is ludicrous. It's good to have a deep dive into munitions. Definitely is. Suicide bombing. He also gives them an envelope.
我是说，这非常有埃里克·安布勒（Eric Ambler）的风格。他给了他们一个信封，说：“这个信封能让你穿过边境，跨过德里纳河，回到波斯尼亚。”基本上，你必须去塞尔维亚西部一个叫沙巴茨（Shabats）的城镇，当你到达边境时，把这个交给特定地点的特定人，他会带你过去。你看，你说这一切听起来太不可信了，听起来像惊悚小说。我认为这其中很多设计都是为了给他们留下深刻印象，对吧？你知道，他们读过这些间谍故事，我觉得这很有可能只是虚张声势。是的，因为弗雷德里克·莫顿（Frederick Morton）在《黄昏时的雷声》（Thunder at Twilight）中讲过一个故事。
I mean, this is very Eric Ambler. He gives them an envelope and he says, this envelope will get you across the border, across the river Drina, back into Bosnia. And and basically you must go to a town called shabbats in western serbia when you get there on the border you give this to a particular man in a particular place and he will get you across you see you said all of this sounds so implausible it sounds like a thriller i think a lot of this is being designed to impress them right you know they've read these stories spy stories and i think a lot of this is very well be flummery yeah because there's a story frederick morton tells this in thunder at twilight
有一个故事说，在他们离开的前一天晚上，也就是1914年5月27日，他们被传唤到贝尔格莱德纳塔利亚街（Natalia Street）的一间地窖里。他们走下去，那里站着一个人，身穿长袍，头戴黑色兜帽。他把他们带进一个房间，桌子上覆盖着黑布。桌上放着一把匕首、一个骷髅、
there's a story that the night before they leave which is the 27th of May, 1914, they are summoned to a cellar at Krakice Natalia Street in Belgrade. And they go down, there's somebody there standing there robed and hooded in black. And he shows them into a room, table draped in black. On the table are a dagger, a skull,
一个十字架、一把左轮手枪和一个贴着死神头像标签的瓶子。这个戴兜帽的人说：“这是‘黑手党’的祭坛。你们必须宣誓。”所以如果他这么说，大概他们当时就知道自己是被“黑手党”操纵的了。你看，有不同的版本。
a crucifix, a revolver, and a bottle with a death's head label. And this guy in the hood says, this is the altar of the Black Hand. You must swear the oath. So if he's saying that, presumably they then know that they are being manipulated by the Black Hand. You see, there are different versions.
因为当然，如果普林西普是自己想出的主意，为什么他需要被……但如果是一个幕后组织在操纵他们，却又试图保持神秘，我不明白为什么它会突然揭露说“我们是黑手党”，除非他们认为还有很长的路要走。对，暗杀还有两个月才发生。首先，这是一件令人恐惧的事情。有可能这个故事完全是胡说八道，我相信很多听众会觉得这简直是无稽之谈，但也有可能人们认为这能稳住他们的神经，让他们感到自己属于一个排他的俱乐部，
Because of course, if Princip has come up with the idea himself, why does he need to be... But if it's a shadowy organization that's manipulating them, but trying to keep secret secret itself i don't see why it would suddenly reveal that we're the black hand right unless they think there's a long way to go right the assassination is two months away it's a frightening thing first of all it's possible the story is total balderdash and i'm sure lots of people listen to this will think absolute tosh but it is possible that people thought this will steady their nerves they will feel a sense of belonging to an exclusive club
不想让任何人失望。我是说，我们从加夫里洛·普林西普写的那段文章中知道，他是一个非常浪漫的人。嗯，我不得不说，我确实很喜欢这种想法，即整件事基本上是为了尽可能看起来像一部间谍惊悚片。是的，这就像勒卡雷（Le Carré）的情节之类的。当然，它正是那样，或者像翁贝托·埃科（Umberto Eco）的《傅科摆》（Foucault's Pendulum），基本上他们发明了所有这些仪式来打动这些男孩。我认为这有可能，虽然他们真的去那里并看到一个戴兜帽的人有点不可信，但他们前一天晚上确实可能为他们上演了一些奇观，比如入会仪式，
not wanting to let anybody down I mean we know from Gavrilo Princip from that fragment that essay that he wrote that he's a very romantic person well I mean I have to say I do love the idea that the whole thing has basically been constructed yeah to seem as much like a spy thriller as possible yeah that's like a kind of le carre plot or something of course it is exactly it is that base or umberto echo the yeah who goes pendulum that basically they've invented all these rituals to impress these boys i think it's possible maybe a tiny bit implausible that they're genuinely going there and there's a hooded figure but possible that they might have put on some spectacle for them the night before you know an initiation ritual to
为了稳住他们的神经。但你刚才说的关于给他们信封并告诉他们必须在某个点过境的事，也许这比实际需要的更戏剧化、更困难。是的，他们把这变成了一场伟大的冒险，一场属于男孩们的冒险。于是，就在第二天，5月28日，他们离开了贝尔格莱德前往波斯尼亚。汤姆，这变得太令人兴奋了，以至于……是的，我们应该休息一下。我们应该休息一下。
steady their nerves but also what you're saying about giving them envelopes and saying you have to cross at a certain point yeah that perhaps that's slightly more dramatic and difficult than it need be yeah that they're making it a great adventure an adventure for the boys and so it is that the very next day the the 28th of May, they leave Belgrade for Bosnia. And Tom, this is getting so exciting that... Yeah, we should take a break. We should take a break.
因为我真的需要在这里喘口气。好吧，天哪。那我们就这么做。我们喘口气。等我们回来时，刺客们就已经进入波斯尼亚了。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
Because I really need to catch my breath here. Okay, crikey. So we'll do that. We'll catch our breath. And then when we come back, the assassins have crossed into Bosnia. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们共同主持《娱乐的本质》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻，波斯尼亚。请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的本质》（The Rest Is History）。加夫里洛·普林西普和他那群快乐的刺客已经离开了贝尔格莱德。是的。也许是被“黑手党”送上路的，也许不是。但多米尼克，可以确定的是，还有很多间谍故事里的把戏即将上演。确实如此。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, Bosnia. head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Gavrilo Princip and his merry band of assassins have left Belgrade. Yeah. Perhaps sent on their way by the Black Hand, perhaps not. But Dominic, what is certain is that there are a lot of spy story shenanigans still to come. There are actually.
所以你说等我们回来时，我们已经进入波斯尼亚了。但实际上，进入波斯尼亚本身就是一个巨大的行动。所以他们带着手枪，带着手榴弹，带着氰化物。他们去了那个叫沙巴茨的地方，
So you said when we come back, we'll have crossed into Bosnia. But actually the crossing into Bosnia is itself a huge operation. So they've got their pistols, they've got their grenades, they've got their cyanide. They go to this place called Shabats,
那是萨瓦河上的一个港口。普林西普的朋友查布里诺维奇（Chabrinovich）非常紧张，说话很兴奋，话也太多了。普林西普训斥了他。现在，当他们到达沙巴茨时，记住，普林西普有那个信封。我是说，这简直太荒谬了。
which is a port on the river Sava. And Chabrinovich, who is Princip's friend, is very nervous and is talking excitedly and talking too much. Princip tells him off. Now, when they get to Shabbat, Princip, remember, had this envelope. I mean, it's absolutely preposterous.
在一家特定的咖啡馆露台——美国咖啡馆（Cafe America），他被告知会找到一位陆军上尉在玩一种特定的纸牌游戏，一种异国情调的纸牌游戏，谁知道那是什么游戏呢，反正不是“拍拍乐”。总之，这个家伙在玩纸牌游戏，普林西普把信封给了他。那个正在玩纸牌游戏的上尉对他的牌友说：“我得和我的侄子去散散步。”这怎么还没被拍成电影？我知道，这太神奇了。他们去散步了。这怎么还没被拍成电影？我知道，这太棒了。
At a particular coffeehouse terrace, the Cafe America, he has been told that he will find an army captain playing a particular game of cards an exotic game of cards who knows what that game was it's not snap anyway so this bloke is playing this game of cards princip gives him the envelope the captain who's playing the card game says to his fellow card players i must go for a walk with my nephew how has this not been made into a film i know it's amazing they go for a walk with my nephew. How has this not been made into a film? I know, it's wonderful.
这太神奇了。他们去散步了半个小时。当普林西普回来时，他带着证明他们是海关官员的文件。他们去住了一家旅馆。为了安全起见，他们把所有的枪支和手榴弹都放进了房间里的炉子里。查布里诺维奇仍然非常焦虑、紧张，话太多。
It's amazing. They go for a walk for half an hour. When Princip returns, he is carrying papers that identify them as customs officers. They go and stay in a hotel. They put all their guns and grenades into the stove, which is in their room for safekeeping. Shabrinovich is still very anxious, nervous, talking too much.
据称，他遇到了一些人，说话太兴奋，外套敞开了，露出了他带着炸弹。所以这简直是一团糟。总之，第二天他们上了火车。他们现在要去一个叫科瓦利亚察（Kovaljaca）的地方，那是河的塞尔维亚一侧。训练他们的那个家伙西加诺维奇（Siganovich）在铁路工作。他给了他们一些文件，基本上是免费车票，还有一张通行证，意味着没人会搜查他们的行李。
Supposedly, he meets some guy and he's talking so excitedly that his coat falls open to reveal that he's carrying bombs. So it's just a shambolic. Anyway, the next day they get on the train. They're going now to a place called Kovaljaca, which is on the Serbian side of the river. And Siganovich, the guy who trains them, worked for the railways. He has given them papers that are basically free tickets and also a pass that means no one will search their luggage.
他们到达河边，普林西普说：“我们必须寄明信片。”这太勒卡雷了，不是吗，汤姆？“我们必须寄明信片给我们的朋友和家人，因为这能掩盖我们的行踪。”他给贝尔格莱德的一个表亲寄了一张明信片，他在明信片里说：“我们必须寄明信片给我们的朋友和家人，因为这能掩盖我们的行踪。”他给贝尔格莱德的一个表亲寄了一张明信片，他在明信片里说：“我要去修道院。”
They get to the river and Princip says, we must send postcards. This is so le carré, isn't it, Tom? We must send postcards to our friends and family because this will cover our tracks. He sends a card to a cousin of his in Belgrade and he says in the card, We must send postcards to our friends and family because this will cover our tracks. He sends a card to a cousin of his in Belgrade and he says in the card, I'm going to a monastery.
“我要去修道院复习准备期末考试。”查布里诺维奇寄了……我是说，他此时已经失控了，不是吗？我是说，他太糟糕了。他给他在奥匈帝国境内的各个朋友寄了明信片，还开了各种民族主义玩笑，说了些民族主义的话。普林西普说：“你知道，你得冷静点。冷静点。”他撕碎了查布里诺维奇的明信片。他把他带到厕所，没收了他的炸弹，
I'm off to a monastery to revise for my finals. So Brinovich sends... I mean, he's out of control by this point, isn't he? I mean, he's terrible. He sends his cards to various friends he has inside the Austrian Empire and making all these kind of nationalist jokes and nationalist sayings. And Princip says, you know, you've got a grip. Get a grip. He tears up Krivovich's cards. He takes him to the toilet, confiscates his bombs
并对他说：“你必须独自前行。你会危及任务的。格拉贝斯（Grabes）和我将分开走。你必须独自前行，我们会在波斯尼亚边境重聚。”所以查布里诺维奇独自离开了。现在普林西普和格拉贝斯必须过河。他们沿着河边折返。他们发现了一段有很多浅滩和小岛的地方。在那里，其中一个小岛是一个类似酒馆的地方，人们在那里酿造自己的白兰地——李子白兰地，并卖给农民，所以这算是一个走私者的窝点。就在这个小酒馆的吧台里，他们遇到了一个被指定为联络员的家伙，这个人要带他们穿过一个浅滩进入波斯尼亚。
and says to him, you must go on on your own. You're going to endanger the mission. Graves and I will go on separately. You have to go on alone and we will reunite across the Bosnian border. So Siprinjic goes off his own way. Now Princip and Grabes have to cross the river. They sort of double back along the river. They find a stretch with lots of shallows and little islets. And there, one of the islets is a kind of drinking den where people brew their own kind of brandy plum brandy and they sell it to peasants so they're kind of smugglers smugglers den and it's there in the bar of this sort of shabin that they meet a guy who's like their designated courier this guy is going to take them across a ford into bosnia
事情就是这样发生的，他们涉水穿过浅滩，然后艰难地穿过田野。我是说，他们相当瘦弱，不是吗？因为普林西普被告知他不能参军，他有肺结核，他有肺结核，所以出于这个原因，他们开始觉得手榴弹、枪支和其他东西非常沉重。是的。他们开始变得非常痛苦。他们陷入了田野的泥泞中。
and this is exactly what happens they splash across the ford they then are trudging across fields they are i mean they're quite weedy aren't they because of course princip was told he couldn't join the army he's got tb hasn't he's got tb so for that reason they start to find the grenades and the gums and their other stuff very heavy. Yeah. They start to become very miserable. They're getting bogged down in the mud of the fields.
所以他们征用了一系列农民的马车来帮助他们，让他们搭便车之类的。他们基本上是在搭便车。而且普林西普，我是说，他们不是出色的间谍特工，
So they commandeer a series of kind of peasants' carts and farmers to help to give them lifts and stuff. They basically hitchhike. And Princip, I mean, they're not brilliant espionage agents
因为普林西普对这些人中的许多人说：“你知道，我们正在执行秘密任务，如果你告诉任何人关于我们或任务的事……”他其实非常有威胁性。我觉得加夫里洛·普林西普是一个非常令人不快的人，因为他对这些农民说：“如果你告诉任何人关于我们任务的事，你和你的家人都会被毁灭。”所以他们身后留下了一点痕迹。我想，总之，没人说什么。所以最后，他们和查布里诺维奇会合了。
because Princip says to a lot of these people, you know, we're on a secret mission if you tell anybody about us or about the mission he's very threatening actually he's a very unpleasant character I think Gavrili Princip because he says to these farmers if you tell anyone about our mission you and your family will be destroyed so they're kind of leaving a bit of a trail I suppose behind them anyway nobody does say anything. So finally, they meet up with Trubinovich.
他不得不分开走。他们随后决定：“哦，带着枪和手榴弹坐火车去萨拉热窝太危险了。”他们决定把它们留给一个他们认为可以信任的电影院老板。抱歉，他是从哪儿冒出来的？
He's got a cross separately. They then decide, oh, it's very dangerous to go on to Sarajevo on the train with the guns and with the grenades. They decide they're going to leave them with a cinema proprietor who they think can be trusted. Sorry, where's he popped up from?
嗯，谁知道呢？他是神秘的“黑手党”的另一部分吗？我不知道，汤姆。这就是许多……例如，所有的联络员，他们是怎么遇到所有联络员的？他们是怎么遇到向导的？对，塞尔维亚的民族主义网络有成千上万的成员，你知道，有成千上万的人加入了这个所谓的“国防组织”，所以完全有可能消息已经传出去了：“有这些家伙要来，帮他们一把。”你知道，我的意思是，他们确实穿过了边境，他们确实一路到了萨拉热窝，所以我们知道这个网络确实存在。但我的意思是，他们留下了巨大的痕迹。但别忘了，他们打算自杀。我知道他们是这么打算的，但即便如此，我的意思是，这很明显，不是吗？他们要来，没人……
Well, who knows? Is he another part of the shadowy black hand i don't know tom and that's one of the many so for example all the couriers how have they met all the couriers have they met the guides right the serbian irredentist nationalist networks have thousands of members and you know there are thousands of people who've signed up to this like national defense organization so it's perfectly possible that word has gone out there are these guys coming just give them a hand you know i mean they did get across the border they did get all the way to sarajevo so we know that the network did exist but i mean they are leaving a massive trail but don't forget they're going to kill themselves i know they are but even so i mean it's kind of obvious isn't it that they're coming no one on
无论是塞尔维亚的……我是说，因为“黑手党”不是塞尔维亚政府的一部分。而塞尔维亚政府很焦虑，我假设，不想因为谋杀奥匈帝国皇位继承人而被指责。所以他们有没有察觉到正在发生的事情？他们察觉到了，是的，我一会儿就讲到这一点，汤姆。所以，为了讲完那个故事，他们留下了武器，他们对电影院老板说：“会有人来，给你看一个特定品牌的香烟。”又是一个非常埃里克·安布勒式的细节——斯蒂芬妮（Stephanie）香烟。然后他们上了火车，去了萨拉热窝，
either the serbian i mean because the black Black Hand is not part of the Serbian government. And the Serbian government is anxious, I assume, not to get fingered for being, you know, the responsibility for murdering the heir apparent to the Austro-Hungarian throne. So were they picking up on what's going on at all? They are picking up on this yeah i'll just get on that in just one sec tom so just to finish that story they left the weapons they said to the cinema guy someone will come and show you a particular brand of cigarettes again a very eric camber detail stephanie cigarettes and then they get on the train and they go to sarajevo
我想他们是在6月4日到达的。所以你是完全正确的，他们留下了痕迹，塞尔维亚政府确实知道有些事情正在酝酿。所以塞尔维亚总理是一个叫尼古拉·帕希奇（Nikola Pasic）的人，他被普遍描述为——这是你字典里对“老狐狸”的定义。对。现在，许多历史学家把帕希奇描绘成一个狡猾的塞尔维亚老农民。我想马克斯·黑斯廷斯（Max Hastings）在他的书中就是这么写的。他是工程师，不是吗？是的，那不太准确。
where they arrive on the fourth i think it it is of June so you're absolutely right they have left a trail and the Serbian government does know something is afoot so the Serbian prime minister is a man called Nikola Pasic and he is described universally, is your dictionary definition of a wily old bird. Right. Now, lots of historians present Pasic as a kind of crafty old Serbian peasant. I think Max Hastings does in his book. He's an engineer, isn't he? Yeah, that's not quite right.
他在苏黎世接受过工程学培训。他是一个非常聪明的人。他领导着塞尔维亚的“激进党”（Radical Party），这是一个吸引了许多许多塞尔维亚农民的民粹主义政党。他是一个非常精明、谨慎的政治家。他亲俄。他是民族主义者。他不像某些人那么激进，但他总是非常热衷于不被超越。但他不是“黑手党”式的民族主义者。他不是“黑手党”式的民族主义者。现在，历史学家对此有分歧，
He had trained in Zurich in engineering. He is a very smart guy. He leads a party called the Radical Party in Serbia, which is a kind of populist party that appeals to the many, many Serbian peasants. He's a very canny, cautious politician. He's pro-Russian. He is nationalist. He's not as nationalist as some, but he's always very keen not to be outflanked. But he's not black hand nationalist. He's not black hand nationalist. Now, historians disagree about this,
但我认为没有理由不同意克里斯托弗·克拉克（Christopher Clarke）和他的书《梦游者》（The Sleepwalkers）。克拉克说，帕希奇几乎肯定知道这个计划。所以，在他们到达萨拉热窝的时候，他可能知道学生们已经过了河，他们有枪，他们得到了边境沿线人们的帮助，他们正在波斯尼亚策划什么。我们之所以能
but I see no reason to disagree with Christopher Clarke and his book, The Sleepwalkers. Clarke says it is virtually certain that Pasic knew about the plan. So about the point that they arrive in Sarajevo, he probably knows that students have crossed the river, that they have guns, that they have been helped by people along the border and they are planning something in bosnia and the reason we can be
相当确定他知道这一点，是因为在20世纪20年代，他的教育部长写了一段回忆录，其中记录了在5月底或6月初，他不记得具体日期了，帕希奇告诉他的内阁：“有人正计划去萨拉热窝刺杀弗朗茨·斐迪南。”他们同意了，内阁同意了，他们应该向边境官员发出指示，试图阻止这些人过境。
pretty sure that he knows this is that in the 1920s his education minister wrote a fragment of a memoir and in that he recorded that at the end of may or beginning of June, he doesn't remember, Passage told his cabinet, there are people who are planning to go to Sarajevo to kill Franz Ferdinand. And they agreed, the cabinet agreed, that they should issue instructions to their border officials to try and prevent these guys from crossing.
那么这些边境官员，他们值得政府信任吗？不，他们不值得。或者他们已经被邪恶的“黑手党”收买了吗？他们已经被收买了。他们是“民族保卫组织”（Narodna Obrana）的成员，如果你愿意的话，这是那个门面组织，那个大型的公共民族主义组织，国防组织。他们绝对不值得信任。所以塞尔维亚国家的框架和结构正在被这种民族主义的、阴暗的恐怖组织所蚕食。正是如此。自1903年国王和王后被谋杀以来，塞尔维亚政治一直处于这种灰色地带，既有官方政治，即你所看到的议会政治，
So these border officials, are they to be trusted by the government? No, they're not. Or have they they to be trusted by the government? No, they're not. Or have they been suborned by the sinister black hand? They've been suborned. They are members of Narodna Obrana, which is the front organization, if you like, the big public nationalist organization, national defense. They absolutely are not to be trusted. And so the frameworks and structures of the Serbian state are being cannibalized by this kind of irredentist, shadowy terrorist organization. Exactly. Ever since 1903 and the murder of the king and queen, Serbian politics has been in this kind of gray area where there is the official politics, parliamentary politics that you see,
但也有与主流政党关系非常密切的准军事和民族主义团体。现在，我们知道到6月中旬，帕希奇知道他们已经越过了边境，他们没有被阻止，因为他要求对边境发生的事情进行调查。为什么准军事组织在控制边境口岸？他在6月24日给他的战争部长发了一封秘密信件，也就是暗杀发生前四天，他在信中说：“我得知边境官员正在从事叛国活动，因为它旨在制造塞尔维亚和奥匈帝国之间的冲突。”他甚至在信中说：“如果我们的盟友知道发生了什么，他们会抛弃我们，因为他们会站在
but there are also paramilitary and nationalist groups who have a very close relationship with mainstream political parties. Now, we know that by mid-June, Pasic knows they have crossed the border, that they haven't been stopped, because he demands an investigation into what is going on on the border. Why are the paramilitaries controlling the border crossings? He sent a secret letter to his war minister on the 24th of june that is four days before the assassination in which he said i have learned that border officers are engaged in treasonable work because it aims at the creation of conflict between serbia and austria hungary and he actually says in that letter if our allies knew what was going on they would desert us because they would be on
奥地利一边，他们会说我们表现得不负责任。”而且更重要的是，帕希奇还下令调查“黑手党”。所以我们可以相当肯定，在主流政治圈子里，人们意识到有些事情正在发生。然而，帕希奇面临两个非常重要的制约因素。制约因素一：当时塞尔维亚正处于一场巨大的政治危机中，他非常担心民族主义者对他发动政变。制约因素二：选举即将到来。如果你放弃民族主义立场，你在塞尔维亚就会输，事情就是这样。是的，好吧，所以我理解这一点，但我的意思是，他所要做的基本上就是告诉奥匈帝国政府，是的，不要派他……
austria's side they would say we are behaving irresponsibly and what is more passage also ordered an investigation into the black hand so we can be pretty confident that in mainstream political circles people are aware that something is going on however there are two really important constraints on passage constraint number one there's a big political crisis in serbia at the time and he's very worried about a coup by the by the nationalists against him number two there's an election coming if you vacate nationalist ground you lose in serbia that's how it works yeah okay so so i understand that but i mean all he has to do is basically tell the the austro-hungarian government yeah don't send him
支持。这是一个巨大的历史学问题。绝对不是，它是。但我的意思是，这是关键问题，不是吗？正如我所说，男孩们在6月4日到达了萨拉热窝。6月5日，一个叫约万·约万诺维奇（Jovan Jovanovic）的人，他是塞尔维亚驻奥匈帝国维也纳大使，他是一个民族主义者，他去见了奥地利财政部长，名叫贝林斯基伯爵（Count Belinsky）。奥地利财政部长是负责管理波斯尼亚-黑塞哥维那的部长之一。约万诺维奇对他说：“你们在波斯尼亚进行军事演习，弗朗茨·斐迪南也会在那里。”他说：“我认为这样做非常危险。”现在，
the support this is that this is a huge issue in the historiography absolutely no it is but i mean this is the key issue isn't it is i said that the boys arrived in sarajevo on the 4th of june on the 5th of june a man called jovan Jovanovic, who was the Serbian ambassador to Austria-Hungary in Vienna, who is a nationalist, he goes to see the Austrian finance minister, who's called Count Belinsky. The Austrian finance minister is one of those ministers who's actually in charge of administering Bosnia-Herzegovina. And Jovanovic says to him, you've got these military exercises taking place in Bosnia and Franz Ferdinand will be there. He says, I think it's very dangerous to do this. Now,
他给出的警告，他说：“我担心的是，一名波斯尼亚塞尔维亚士兵在军事演习中会装上实弹，而不是空包弹，并向弗朗茨·斐迪南开枪。所以在这种情况下，我认为你们应该完全取消这些演习。”但为什么他不直说呢？因为我的意思是，这太含糊了。这非常含糊。当然，坎巴林斯基（Kambalinski）并没有认真对待。他说：“我相信我们没问题。”他为什么要认真对待呢？
the warning he gives, he says, my worry is that a Bosnian Serb soldier in the military exercises will load his rifle, not with blanks, but with a real cartridge, and will shoot it at Franz Ferdinand. So in the circumstances, I think you should just call off these exercises completely. But why isn't he being upfront and saying, because I mean, that's very elliptical. It's very elliptical. Of course, Kambalinski doesn't take it seriously. He says, I'm sure we're fine. Why would he?
是的。因为它听起来没有来源。我的意思是，这听起来像是猜测。我认为历史学家的论点是，塞尔维亚政府觉得警告没有任何好处，因为这会让奥地利人暴跳如雷。奥地利人会说：“你们不能控制自己的人民、你们自己的情报机构吗？”我不这么认为。
Yeah. Because it doesn't sound sourced. I mean, it sounds a speculation. I think the argument from historians is that the Serbian government feel they have nothing to gain from a warning because it will make the Austrians go ballistic. The Austrians will say, can't you control your own people, your own intelligence agency? I don't think so.
我认为，你知道，说有一个流氓分子要来，我们的警察已经发现了。但别忘了塞尔维亚人和奥地利人的关系并不好。让他们去对他们说“我们国家内部有一个流氓分子，我们没能阻止它”，我想他们希望什么都不会发生，希望它会失败。嗯，我想也是。而且更重要的是……
I think, you know, saying there's a rogue element that's coming and our police have rumbled it. But don't forget the Serbians and the Austrians do not have good relations. For them to go to them and to say there's a rogue element within our own state, we've failed to prevent it, I think they are hoping that nothing will come of it, that it will fail. Well, I suppose. And what is more...
但他们害怕奥匈帝国对他们宣战，如果他们卷入其中。我的意思是，那是一场巨大的灾难。但帕希奇也害怕失败。他不想输掉选举。他不想让民族主义网络反过来对付他。如果事情曝光了怎么办？
But they're terrified of Austria-Hungary declaring war on them, if they're implicated in it. I mean, that's a massive disaster. But also, Pasic is terrified of losing. He doesn't want to lose the election. He doesn't want the nationalist networks to turn on him. What if it came out?
如果奥地利人公开了怎么办？“我们取消军事演习，因为我们收到了塞尔维亚政府的消息。”帕希奇在国内会陷入可怕的麻烦。对他来说是多么尴尬。现在，你很可能会说，汤姆，另一个问题是，即使有这样模糊的警告，为什么奥地利人不改变他们的计划？
What if the Austrians went public? We're calling off the military exercises because we've had word from the Serbian government. Pasic would be in terrible trouble at home domestically. What an embarrassment for him. Now, you might well say, Tom, the other question is, even with such a vague warning, why don't the Austrians change their plans?
嗯，首先，因为警告太模糊了，他们觉得没必要改变。但其次，他们认为——我想贝林斯基伯爵认为塞尔维亚大使只是想恐吓他们。他想让我们取消演习，是的，因为他想让我们看起来软弱和分裂，而我们想展示我们是多么权威，我们是多么自信。我们不会仅仅因为什么都没有就取消它们。所以，一切照常进行。6月4日，正如我所说，
Well, first of all, because the warning is so vague,'re like they're not going to change them but secondly they think i think count belinsky thinks the serbian ambassador is just trying to intimidate he wants us to call off the exercises yeah because he wants us to look weak and divided and we want to show how authoritative we are and how confident we are we're not going to just call them off for nothing. So, everything goes ahead. On the 4th of June, as I said,
男孩们到达了萨拉热窝。普林西普搬回了伊利奇夫人（Mrs. Illich）的房子，那是他最初寄宿的女人。而那个
the boys had arrived in Sarajevo. Princip moves back into the house of Mrs. Illich, the woman with whom he had first lodged. And the guy
戴着黑领带以便反思死亡的人，达尼洛·伊利奇（Danilo Illich）。现在，取决于你读的是哪个版本，唯一的答案是我们不可能知道。有可能普林西普写信给伊利奇说：“有一个
who wears a black tie so he can reflect on death. Danilo Illich. Now, depending which version of this you read and the only answer is we cannot possibly know it's possible that princip has written to illich and said to him there's a
阴谋，我很想让你参与进来。”有可能，实际上一些历史学家认为这从头到尾都是伊利奇的主意，而不是普林西普的。也有可能，我认为最有可能的是，他们俩都被网络培养了，伊利奇是其中的一部分。伊利奇有三个他自己的新兵，两个叫波波维奇（Popovich）和查布里洛维奇（Chabrilovich）的高中生，他们是来自萨拉热窝的波斯尼亚塞尔维亚人，有趣的是，还有一个波斯尼亚穆斯林。是的，我的意思是这很有趣，因为它拓宽了那种认为这是一个非常狭隘的沙文主义塞尔维亚阴谋的想法，尽管它潜伏在背景中。我的意思是，也许这正是它的本质。是的。这个家伙很有趣。他叫梅赫梅特·巴齐奇（Mehmet Bazic）。他实际上是一个奥斯曼地主的儿子，他是一个某种自我厌恶的奥斯曼地主的儿子。所以他实际上放弃了他的一些财富来赎回他的农奴。
plot i'd love you to be in on it it's possible actually some historians think that it was illich's idea not princip's all along it's also possible probably most likely i think that both of them have been groomed by the network and that ilitch is part of this ilitch has got three recruits of his own two high school students called popovich and chabrilovich who are bosnian serbs from sarajevo and interestingly a bosnian muslim yeah i mean that is interesting because it broadens it out from the idea that this is a very narrowly chauvinist Serb conspiracy, even though lurking in the background. I mean, maybe that's precisely what it is. Yes. This guy's interesting. He's called Mehmet Bazic. He's actually the son of an Ottoman landlord and he's a sort of self-hating son of an Ottoman landlord. So he had actually given up some of his fortune to buy his serfs out.
他放弃伊斯兰教了吗？那我就不知道了，汤姆。那会是一个有趣的问题，但我不知道。因为塞尔维亚民族主义者、“黑手党”和所有人的计划不是认为穆斯林被视为塞尔维亚人，因此应该放弃伊斯兰教并回归母教会的怀抱吗？我怀疑他不会对那个想法非常热衷。因为别忘了，很多参与这个组织的男孩
Has he given up Islam? That I do not know, Tom. That would be an interesting question, but I don't know. Because isn't the plan for the Serb nationalists, the Black Hand and everybody, that Muslims are seen as Serbs and therefore should give up Islam and return to the bosom of the Mother Church? I suspect he wouldn't be terribly keen on that idea. Because don't forget, a lot of these boys who are involved in the organization
梦想的是一个南斯拉夫，而不是某种大塞尔维亚。他们基本上都是同一种人，所有这些男孩，除了关于梅赫梅特·巴齐奇的有趣细节外。他们不喝酒，他们没有女朋友，他们是流浪者，他们是失败者，他们沉迷于殉道和牺牲以及所有这些事情。所以他们都差不多。是伊利奇去从电影院老板那里拿到了武器，给他看了香烟，把它们带回了萨拉热窝，
are dreaming of a Yugoslavia rather than a sort of greater serbia they're all pretty much the same person all of these boys apart from the interesting detail about mehmet bazic they they don't drink they don't have girlfriends they are drifters they are losers they are obsessed with martyrdom and sacrifice and all these kinds of things. So they're all much of a muchness. It's Illich who goes and gets the weapons from the cinema proprietor, shows him the cigarettes, brings them back to Sarajevo,
奇怪地把它们存放在他母亲房子里床下的一个袋子里。所以不是一个非常令人兴奋的埃里克·安布勒式的地点。但他随后带着他的小伙子们出去，教他们如何使用枪支等等。所以我想你可以说有两组人，汤姆，参与了这次行动。一组来自贝尔格莱德，另一组已经在萨拉热窝了。他们并没有真正混合在一起。所以普林西普和伊利奇混合了，但其他人根本没有。他们找到了大公的路线，
stores them bizarrely in a bag under a bed in his mother's house. So not a very exciting Eric Ambler location. But he then takes his lads out and shows them how to use the guns and all that kind of thing so there are two cells i suppose you might say tom involved in the operation the one group from belgrade the other group are already in sarajevo they don't really mix so princip and illich mix but the others don't at all they find the um archduke's route
来自一份叫《波斯尼亚邮报》（Debosnische Post）的德语报纸。伊利奇可以翻译它，因为他会说德语。他们看了路线。计划是——我们将在第四集中详细讨论这一点——大公将到达火车站。他将沿着我们走过的河边开车，我们走过的那条路，汤姆。他们将沿着河边这条非常直的路走。如果你是刺客，这简直太完美了，你只需要等待。你实际上可以沿着路散开。所以这就是计划。日子临近了。他们都很紧张，但他们保持着冷静。他们在6月27日下午见面。那是一个下雨、阴沉、多云的日子，气氛有点忧郁，但他们在一家酒吧见面，加夫里洛·普林西普破天荒地喝了酒。这是他唯一一次被看到喝酒，当然，
from a german language paper called the debosnische Post. Illich can translate it because he can speak German. They look at the route. The plan is, we'll go into this more in our fourth episode, the Archduke is going to arrive at the railway station. He's going to drive along the river where we have been, the walk we've done, Tom. They're going to go along this very straight road by the river. It is perfect if you're an assassin, you can just wait. You can actually spread out along the road. So that is the plan. The day approaches. They are all nervous, but they're holding their nerve. They meet on the afternoon of the 27th of June. It is a rainy, gray, over overcast day the mood is kind of somber but they meet in a wine bar and for once gavrilo princip drinks it's the one time he was ever seen to drink wine of course
因为他认为他明天就要死了。计划是让他们自杀。我的意思是，非常像9/11的阴谋者，绝对是，他们出去并同样在之前喝酒。是的，完全一样。当他们离开时，你知道，握手或什么的，他们说：“我们明天早上见，我们在城里的弗利尼奇（Vlinich）糕点店见面，吃个糕点，然后在大公的车队沿途占据我们的位置。”他们有炸弹，有手枪，一切都准备好了。那天晚上，加夫里洛·普林西普做了最后一件事，完全符合他到目前为止所做的一切。他最后一次去朝圣了波格丹·泽里奇（Bogdan Zerich）的坟墓，那个在1910年未能
because he thinks he's going to be dead tomorrow the plan is for them to kill themselves i mean very like the 9-11 conspirators absolutely who went out and similarly drank yeah before exactly as they leave you know shake hands or whatever they say we'll meet tomorrow morning we'll meet at eight o'clock we'll meet at the vlinich pastry shop in town get a pastry and then take our places along the road for the archduke's cavalcade they've got their bombs they've got their pistols everything is ready and that night Gavrilo Princip does one last thing totally in keeping with everything he's done up to this point he makes a last pilgrimage to the grave of Bogdan Zerich the terrorist who had failed to
杀死波斯尼亚总督的恐怖分子，那个激励了他这么多的家伙，那个他希望追随其脚步的烈士。他相信明天他会成功，而泽里奇失败了。当然，他自己也会死。他会结束自己的生命，他会把自己的名字写进塞尔维亚的民间传说中，毫无疑问地证明他不是一个弱者，他是一个真正的男人。哇。好吧，真是个悬念。我的意思是，整个系列只是一连串的悬念。当然，我们将看看1914年6月28日那个决定性的一天发生了什么。我们将一步一步地经历它，就像我们处理肯尼迪遇刺事件一样。但在那之前，我认为我们应该看看那个目标人物，
kill the Bosnian governor the guy who had inspired him so much in 1910, the martyr in whose footsteps he hopes to follow. And he believes that tomorrow he will succeed where Zarić failed. And he himself, of course, will be dead. He will have taken his own life and he will have written his name into Serbian folklore, having proved beyond any doubt that he is not a weakling and that he is a real man. Wow. Well, what a cliffhanger. I mean, this whole series is just a succession of cliffhangers. And of course, we will be looking at what happens on the fateful day of the 28th of June, 1914. And we'll be going through it step by step, rather like we did with the events of the Kennedy assassination. But before that, I think that we should look at the man who is the target
这个阴谋的受害者，那个被谋杀者，大公弗朗茨·斐迪南，实际上，我不得不说，我认为他是一个比我之前意识到的更有趣、更有吸引力的人物。我们将看看他以及他运作的整个背景——奥匈帝国。如果你是《历史的本质》俱乐部的成员，你可以马上收听。如果你不是，你可以在 therestishistory.com 注册。今天的内容太棒了，多米尼克。非常感谢。希望你喜欢。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持
of this conspiracy, the victim of it, the murdery, Archduke Franz Ferdinand, who actually, I have to say, I think is a much more interesting and attractive character than I'd appreciated. We'll be looking at him and the whole context in which he operates the Austro-Hungarian empire. And you can listen to that right away if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club. And if you're not, you can sign up for it at therestishistory.com. Brilliant stuff today, Dominic. Thanks ever so much. I hope you've enjoyed it. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host
《娱乐的本质》，这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐界的帷幕，
The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment
我们告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们为您讲述这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。